seven quick Easter eggs you might have
missed in House of the Dragon episode 9.
in the intro credits the symbol for King
viserys is now covered in blood
indicating his death when Allison tells
her father of the King's death you can
see her pick at her nails a habit that's
been with her all the way since episode
1. Helena has shown to have some cryptic
prophecies telling her mother to beware
the Beast beneath the boards
foreshadowing renice's attack from below
the dragon pit at the end of the episode
Demon Done the search for his brother
tells sir Kristen that he's probably
halfway to yiti by now ET is a
civilization far off to the east with a
spin-off animated show about it
currently in the works winter Eric
escapes with renise he has this Satchel
which most likely carries king viserys's
crown that Allison put on the king's
corpse Prince aegon's hiding location is
the same except his mother and raniera
prayed at in episode 2. renice decides
not to burn all the greens which would
have prevented the upcoming Civil War
but if you want to find out why she did
this check out my YouTube channel think
story which has even more content